you ready for this go for it
your weapon you'll kill
the ultimate forged and fired matchup
you forged and fire Champion two
Champion playing in a deadly weapon
Showdown it will kill 20 blades 20
Champions you decide the winner forged
in fire Madness
[Music]
the Japanese great sword my name is Ian
zierman I'm 19 years old and I'm from
the small rural town of Bedford
Pennsylvania
probably what got me started making
blades was just my dad being a carpenter
we made a lot of wooden blades and I
looked at him I said wouldn't it be cool
if this was metal and he's like let's do
it the Japanese Greatsword Rose in
popularity during the 14th century
reaching Links of up to five feet long
this massive single head slightly curved
blade was designed to deliver deep
penetrating Cuts upon enemy soldiers on
foot or on Horseback alike
while this enormous weapon became too
impractical for battle by the 17th
century it can still be seen in many
action films including the classic 1954
Carousel movie Seven Samurai
the nine foot long fry Outlet spice my
name is David Warner I'm 37 years old
I'm from Kirkwood Missouri I have twins
boy and a girl and I would say that
raising twins has prepared me really
well for this competition because I can
deal with stressful situations the
prowler spice dates back to 16th century
Northern Italy the massive pole arm
features a 37 inch long Central Blade
with two curved side blades the shaft
could measure up to six feet long
perfect for delivering lethal thrusts
and slashes upon enemy Cavalry over time
this enormous weapon took on a more
ceremonial role and at its longest
spanned more than 10 feet today the
prowler spice can be seen on display at
the Metropolitan Museum of Art in New
York City
we're back in our home Forge in Bedford
Pennsylvania that's day one I'm excited
first thing I'm going to do is just try
to Forge office blade it is a Monster
Blade and I just want to get it all
roughed out oh yeah I'm so glad I have a
press I know that I can draw a material
quickly with that all right so we are
pretty much at length to where I want to
be I'm pretty much done and I'm ready to
get it up to temperature and quench it
so my gas forge isn't actually big
enough to do the Heat Treating so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to dig a
ditch and make a kind of like a redneck
coal Forge I have the blade in there I'm
just watching the temperature and just
making sure I don't overheat it things
are definitely heating up literally
this hardened I am really happy with how
it came out sweet
so next thing I need to do is I need to
shape this handle and get it actually
ergonomic and feeling good in your hands
because this handle is pretty big all
right it's starting to fit my hands
really good I really like it it is now a
fully functional sword this thing is a
beast so I got the cashier put on uh
it's shaped I really like it I am ready
for um yeah making it look cool I start
wrapping this handle it's going really
nicely a brown and black contrast is
awesome it's starting to look like a
finished product
there we go very nice fit
cool
it's the beginning of day one I'm ready
to get started on the frialis splice
this is a huge build I'm kind of nervous
about uh making something that's this
size and then to put a sphere socket at
the end of it that's also a challenge
I think that that along with budgeting
enough time to be able to forge out the
side blades and then get them to attach
to the socket you know it's going to be
a pacing challenge I need to start
shaping the handle I've made some Spears
before but nothing quite like this
so I need to make sure that the handle
will actually fit inside the socket I've
got to make sure that there's a pretty
precise fit so I think what I'm going to
do is heat up
this guy and try and uh use that heat to
press this in the hose spice around
there to get a nice seal on that shaft
that's what I was going for yesterday I
got the blades quenched I just need to
assemble everything and sharpen it
because of the size of this blade you
got a bit of a difficulty trying to get
the Contours of those smaller blades
onto the belt grinder without having
anything come into contact with the belt
grinder that shouldn't but I think that
the edge is going to be pretty good on
the blade
I think this blade has got a pretty good
shot of bringing home 10 000 bucks
it was hungry
placements welcome to the dynamic heel
test
that's what great disappointment that I
have to say that I will not be able to
wield your weapons to test it but Dave
Baker will be enjoying and doing your
tests
Ian you're first you ready for this go
for it
foreign
so Ian right off scale wise perfect for
my hand the wrap is really well dialed
in your blade every single one of those
cuts it was deadly your Edge is still a
razor blade it lost no Edge whatsoever
nicely done thank you David you're up
you ready for this yes I am all right
let's do this
foreign
it's pretty wild it went into the pig
with no resistance whatsoever the blade
it's all still true it's all still sharp
nicely done Doug you got anything to add
your weapon you'll kill
all right blade Smiths welcome to my
Dynamic test they steal wind chime and
fish slice
Ian you're on first you ready for this
not really
well get ready it's coming
[Music]
foreign
first things first I'm impressed this
Edge doesn't really show much of any
indication that had been smashed into
steel wind chimes you know you could see
the cuts on all these fish are nice and
clean the handle wrap is really
comfortable the dimensions are good all
in all nice job thank you
bladesmiths welcome to the dynamic
strength test
to test the strength and overall
construction of your weapons I will be
pushing on these poles snapping all 10
of them and then piercing these steel
drums you ready yes I am all right
see
foreign
David well your blade held up great in
piercing the drums took some serious
flex but came right back to true the
side blades here they penetrated that
barrel and I don't even see any
indication that they were in there all
in all I think he did a great job and uh
your weapon held upgrade
thank you now it's your turn which
weapon will you choose forged and fire
Madness